And as before we obtained the very best approximation to theta, with probability greater than 40%.
That's pretty amazing. But if 40% is not good enough
as a measure of confidence,
what we can do is to run the procedure a small number of times, and
take the mode of the outcomes, meaning the one that
appears most frequently.
And if we do that, we'll be extremely likely to end up with a very good approximation to theta.
Remember by the way that every time we run the
phase estimation procedure we have that the eigenvector
comes out unchanged.
So it is available for us to run the procedure
multiple times like this.
In short, we're gathering
statistics about theta, and the point is that by doing this we can get a very precise
approximation to theta
with very high confidence, and we don't need that many iterations of the procedure to do this.
And that is how the phase
estimation procedure works.
In the last part of the lesson, we'll apply the technique
of phase estimation to the integer factorization problem.
As I mentioned at the start of the video, the way this works is that we consider an intermediate problem known as the order finding problem.
We'll see how we can solve
the order finding problem using phase estimation, and then we'll briefly discuss how solving the order finding problem
allows us to factor integers efficiently.
The second part is completely classical and I'll only summarize the
basic idea in this video.
But let's begin with the
order finding problem.
First, let's get some
handy notation in place.
For every positive integer N, we define ZN to be the integers
zero through N minus one.
So for instance, Z one has a
single element which is zero, Z two has elements zero and one,
z three has elements zero,
one and two, and so on.
So ZN is a set.
But we can also think about
it as more than a set. We can think about arithmetic operations like addition and multiplication on ZN
by defining them modular N.
For example, let's suppose
N is equal to seven.
We have that three and five
are elements of Z seven and if we multiply them together we get 15
which leaves a remainder of
one after dividing by seven.
Sometimes we express this by writing that three times five is
congruent to one module seven, like is written here.
But we can also simply write that three times five equals one.
Of course three times five
isn't normally equal to one, it's equal to 15.
But when it's clear that
we're working in Z seven meaning that multiplication
is defined modular seven,
we can simply write that
three times five equals one.
Now among the elements
of ZN for any positive N, some of them will have
GCD equal to one with N
and some won't. And the elements that do have GCD equal to one with N are special.
and we write ZN star to refer to the set of just these elements.
So for example, here's Z 21 star.
among the elements of Z 21, which there are 21 of course, it turns out that 12 of them have GcD equals of one
with 21 and the rest don't.
In particular anytime that
we have an element of Z 21 that's divisible by either
three or seven, we skip it.
There are various reasons
why this set is special, and one of the reasons is that anytime we have an element of ZN star
and we consider the positive
integer powers of that number, we will always eventually
hit the number one,
where just like before we're talking about multiplication modular N.
the smallest positive integer power that gives us one is called
the order of that element.
For example, think about the element A equals four in Z 21 star.
four times four is 16, which is not equal to one modular of 21, but if we multiply by four one more time,
we get 64, and 64 modular
21 is equal to one.
So the order of four modular 21 is three.
Getting to one like this always happens for all of the elements of ZN star.
And by the way, it never
happens for elements of ZN that aren't in ZN star.
So having GCD equal to
one with N like this is both necessary and
sufficient for this to happen.
And just to finish up the
example of N equals 21, here are the smallest
positive integer powers for which this works for
each element of Z 21 star,
and they can each be checked one by one.
And now we can state the
order finding problem, which is simply to find the order for a given element in ZN star.